but I have to say of all the movies I've
ever seen of all the movies I've ever
loved my favorite film franchise of all
time Star Wars I love Star Wars
they teach us so many valuable lessons
one of which is not the value of a human
life
you go back to 1977 the very first one
episode four a new hope they blow up a
planet
seven billion people die 30 minutes
later we're having a metal ceremony did
you have to kill an entire planet of
people George was anybody halfway
through Star Wars you're like I'm not
sure who I'm rooting for yet this is
and then Force awakens was even worse
because Force awakens they don't blow up
one planet they blew up five
billion people died 20 minutes later
we're laughing because the wookie's cold